snap rogers looking pump fakes now
still looking under pressure throws it
right side of the end zone is it caught
it is part of the back line of the end
touchdown
to jamal williams my goodness
in the far right corner of the end zone
they beat morris claiborne
i gave up on the play i thought he was
throwing it away he was not i was
actually throwing a
ball that uh
i thought maybe jimmy could go up and
get if he wanted to and if he didn't
the guy behind him might be able to get
um
luckily the guy behind him
got it that was
uh that was one of the best if not the
best pass i've ever seen live in person
i that was incredible i couldn't believe
it he's a future hall of fame
quarterback and he made a couple
hall of fame throws there those guys you
know they've
don't know how the ball got in there a
couple of those their hands were right
there and um
some gun got him in there so he did it
did a nice shot
aaron rodgers battle floor andy reid
respectively in the aftermath of last
night's 31-24 win by the green bay
packers over the kansas city chiefs the
show's pft live nbc sports radio and
bcsn hello to our friends in the uk and
ireland enjoying the program on sky
sports and chris
every time we do on football night in
america a top five throws for a
quarterback he comes out in that game
and has better throws than what we had
on the top five list for the season to
date i mean that thing from roger to the
back corner of the end zone
i it's you have to watch it 50 times do
you even process what the heck happened
no well i mean i think the there's so
many levels to the the greatness of the
throw first of all i appreciate his
honesty not going like oh i was all to
the guy in the back of the end zone the
whole time like he still did mention the
guy in the back well he saw it it looked
like he was gonna stop short and say you
know i was just hoping jimmy graham
would jump up and get it and then
otherwise it would go out of bounds but
he said or maybe the guy in the back of
the end zone make a play but which i do
believe i mean he's like one of those
guys with patrick mahomes where you know
yeah you would think it's luck but if
you didn't see it you know nine out of
ten times you know that's what kind of
proves you're wrong to go oh it's not
luck but i mean one the way he threw it
at first i went oh my gosh he's not
gonna be able to get this out of bounds
he's trying to throw this out of bounds
and then just to be able to flick it the
way he does 25 yards as you're falling
down and put it in a spot that was safe
for maybe jimmy graham does get it you
know if he doesn't okay it falls out of
the back of the end zone but uh jamal
williams was there and that was uh truly
one of the best plays we saw yesterday
all together i also think that there is
i don't want to call it an intimidation
factor but
when you know that you're facing aaron
rodgers in a moment like that
and you're running around trying to
cover the receivers
there's just something that just you you
almost concede an inevitability yeah
yeah right right my homes see him break
the pocket you just go up here we go and
it's not a fear per se because i hate to
use that word in the context of football
i mean anybody's afraid out there but
it's just you know he's going to make
something happen just like the jimmy
graham touched down in week one where he
just kind of threw it up and popped it
up and oh there he is and mitchell
trubiki trubisky tries something some of
that later in the game and gets picked
off there's just something baked into
who aaron rodgers is and his body of
work that i think creates a sense of
resignation that he's going to find a
way to pull a rabbit out of the hat even
if everybody is doing everything they
can possibly do to try to slow him down
well yes i think that's why you hear
like guys like vic fangio you know two
weeks ago say he's that guy he's been
that guy for the last 12 or 13 years
when fangio was talking about patrick
mahomes being that new guy he instills
great confidence in their football team
when you have a quarterback like that
you know they always believe they can
win no matter what the what the scenario
or the point of the football game or
whatever the obstacle is and yes the
other side is
is sitting there going oh gosh he's got
the ball it's late in the game we've
seen this story before there's a
wizardry to it right there there's a an
element and and i i sense it
even more with him than i do with tom
brady because tom brady's genius is
before the place starts he knows who's
going to be open yes right and he gets
rid of the football he's got the defense
red he knows exactly what he's facing he
knows exactly who's going to be open and
that's the end of it with rogers it's
like he can put everyone else in slow
motion
while he's back there at full speed and
and he's he's got that nonchalance yeah
that somehow he can retain even when
he's being chased by all these guys and
they're trying to and you know he's 35
now like he's not going to be able to
outrun these guys forever but he knows
exactly what his body can do in relation
to everyone else he knows when to slide
because you know it's
that three-dimensional it's almost like
he's operating in four dimensions where
he knows here's when i have to slide
here's what i have to throw here's what
i have to do and he's always in command
of that
even when it feels like chaos is
breaking out around him yeah so that's
where i think he's better than brady
that that he can do all of this
in the midst of chaos right brady needs
something that's more structured and
controlled and i know what i'm doing and
i'm getting rid of the football and
let's go and let's move to the next play
yeah rogers can extend it and then find
something that we don't expect but he
expects yeah well you know again
and this tom brady is amazing what he
does but the system is so great there
too and everything and he works it to
such a great way and all these plays
that you're talking about you know they
have like you know plan one plan two
plan a plan b for everything and he is
just uh he is you know uh surgical as
far as executing that offense and then
knowing what defense you're on rogers
it's a little bit more of yes a little
more maybe let's say fly by the the seat
of your pants at some point at some
times when he drops back to pass and
then you know
the offense sometimes really goes
through him i mean you heard chris sinal
talk about it last night where lefleur
has said in the fourth quarter i feel
like i'm not working because i kind of
just let rogers do his thing like he's
that good at calling the plays and doing
that to where you know it's
it's more peyton manning-ish that way to
where they just kind of sit back and go
hey we've taught you all week you've
taught us two things you like go ahead
run the show
that doesn't necessarily happen across
the nfl right now i think rogers is one
of the few people that's really doing it
that way i mean the best example i can
come up with and this this is it's far
from ideal but but it's almost like
brady is the master surgeon who will be
completely prepared for every procedure
know exactly what he needs to do yeah
and have it all planned out and it will
go according to plan he will ensure
everything goes accordingly listen to
coach coach i mean this i'm going to do
that and make sure everybody does it and
does it the right way and and rogers is
the guy who says let's just go cut this
bastard open
there and i'll figure it out that's
exactly what it is i mean look at some
of the plays in the huddle and again
aaron rod he he's hey all line you block
this i think he's making up plays
sometimes you block this hey you guys
over there run this one you guys over
here run that one and i'll say set high
and don't worry it'll work out i'll
figure it out and it's just uh it is it
is fun to watch and of course it goes
down to the end of the play clock a lot
too because of that and here's here's
the other thing that i want to say
because i have been excessively praising
aaron rodgers over the past couple of
weeks i was the first one on the aaron
rodgers for mvp training
oh his stats don't back it up who cares
about the stats you watch the games yeah
and the stats do back it up now but you
know now that everything's going great
everybody wants to say oh there was
never an issue between aaron rodgers and
matt lafleur yes there was and rogers
won and matt leflore was wise to let him
win right right rogers had to take it
public to win that was not an accident
and i know you and i disagree about
whether or not it was a good thing to
take it public right but he had to take
it public to win it and he did and it
worked that's the bottom line it is the
bottom line i don't disagree with you in
that aspect
my my whole thing was you know at least
they were being honest and getting it
out there instead of just being like
like telling whispers to certain people
around the nfl behind closed doors
that's the thing i appreciate it but
you're right rogers did win we know why
he won and matt lafleur deserves a lot
of credit for that for checking his ego
at the door in certain scenarios like
this it's like tony dungy you know the
great defensive coach oh wait now i have
peyton manning well he doesn't really
play the style i want to play as the
head coach but damn the results speak
for themselves okay peyton you do your
thing and don't worry i'll coach the
defense over here and i give matt
lefleur a lot of credit for that because
that's not easy for a offensive play
caller young guy who's trying to assert
his authority but he has found a balance
to still assert his authority while
letting rogers have his authority as
well and we were concerned about matt
laflin as a head coach could he command
a room could he get it done that way and
if we're going to call aaron rodgers an
mvp candidate yeah matt leflore is the
coach of the year candidate no question
brian gudykunst is an executive of the
year candidate it's that simple it is
they're all of them and they're running
and and here they are seven and one the
back half of the schedule there's some
challenges there there's some tough
games floating around there i could see
them finishing 13 and three or 12 and
four sure and who knows what that
delivers in the nfc especially with the
vikings still hot on their heels only
one game behind right but this packers
team has been phenomenal the defense
stepped up early in the year when the
offense was still trying to find its way
the defense is a concern now isn't it
337 yards allowed to matt moore and
company right last night yeah no the
defense has been a concern the last few
weeks they can't stop the run because of
that they got to be a little more daring
with their coverages to stop the run uh
so they put their corners in some tough
positions at times you know there's a
lot of like a lot to like about what
kansas city did last night i really
think in a lot of ways patrick mahomes
being out is going to be a blessing in
disguise and the big picture of things
for the chiefs and the afc it's going to
make their defense better because
they've had a play here the last two
weeks where they just go oh okay we
can't just depend on mahomes to pull it
out for us so that's and then i think
andy reid what we saw last night made
him go back to the drawing board a
little bit and come up with some new
creative plays to add into the offense
made them run the ball a hair more i
think those are things that can help
them especially when it comes time to
having to play you know afc playoff
football and having to play the patriots
ultimately because that's what we're
going to measure them against because
the patriots are the kings of the afc it
feels inevitable that at some point the
green bay packers will be facing the new
orleans saints in the postseason who
knows that there's a lot of great teams
in the nfc and maybe they won't cross
paths but the saints
also continue to get it done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports